wir waren das obst und gemüse für unsere
familie fast komplett selber an dem dem
bereich können wir uns also sehr sehr
gut selbst versorgen aber kalorien
nächste kommt bei obst und gemüse nicht
so wirklich warum also die kalorien die
wir zu uns nehmen die kaufen wir ja
immer noch ganz normal im laden ein in
form von getreide öl und so weiter und
in diesem video möchte ich euch auf ein
gedankenexperiment einladen weil ich
immer wieder die frage gestellt bekomme
ob es möglich ist sich mit essen
komplett selber zu versorgen zu wirklich
100 prozent für uns ist die
selbstversorgung mehr so ein hobby weil
wir es lieben richtig gutes essen zu
haben weil gemüse aus dem eigenen garten
einfach viel besser schmeckt als das
gekaufte weil man da alte sorten anbauen
kann die man im laden überhaupt nicht
mehr bekommt aber ich finde es total
spannend dass man durchzuspielen um mal
zu überlegen was ich wirklich anders
machen würde wenn ich meine familie
komplett selbst versorgen würde und wie
ich das angehen würde
[Musik]
wir haben neben unseren gemüsegarten
also auch die hühner wir müssen also
keine eier mehr im supermarkt kaufen was
wir aber kaufen müssen ist hühnerfutter
hundertprozentige selbstversorgung ist
das also nicht wenn ich mich zu 100
prozent selbst versorgen würde würde ich
das ein bisschen anders aufziehen
erstens bekommen unsere hühner das
teuerste futter dass es überhaupt gibt
das ist regional angebautes biofutter
das wirklich viel viel teurer ist wenn
man konventionelles futter kauft oder
was offen siegen weit kommt oder sonstwo
her was ich aber ethisch nicht vertreten
könnte deswegen hoffen wir eben dass
regionale bio futter aber wirtschaftlich
ist das ganze nicht ich denke dass wenn
die eier im supermarkt kaufen würden
dass wir ungefähr auf den gleichen preis
auskommen werden wie ich bin die hunde
eigene kinder selber füttern
das liegt auch daran dass wir sehr viele
alte händen haben wo ich es nicht übers
herz bringen die zu schlachten auf zero
legehennen berliner in der
massenproduktion nach 16 monaten spätes
nicht geschlachtet weil es da nicht mehr
wirtschaftlich wäre wir haben jetzt muss
er die geschäfte und rennt über sechs
jahre alte legen kaum noch einer wir
haben acht händen und klingen wenn es
hochkommt drei eier am tag von denen
wenn wir uns zu 100 prozent
selbstversorgung hören dann müssen wir
unser futter selber anbauen und dann
werden wir wahrscheinlich auch nicht
diese ganzen alte handy überhaupt keine
eier mehr legen immer noch behalten
einfach nur weil sie es sind und weil
wir sie so lieb haben dann werden wir
schon härter sein müssen sie dann auch
schlachten weil so ist das alles
überhaupt nicht wirtschaftlich
sinnvollen ich bin sehr froh dass es das
nicht sein muss dass wir das als hobby
machen
wir haben ja gar nicht den anspruch dass
wir uns zu 100 prozent selber versorgen
wollen und alles komplett selber machen
wollen aber bei unserem
gedankenexperiment wäre es eben
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht möglich
diese alten handy immer noch mit
durchzufüttern
wenn wir uns zu 100 prozent selbst
versorgen wollen würden dann würden wir
auch unsere gartenfläche warum einiges
vergrößern müssen im moment haben wir
ungefähr 300 quadratmeter reine beet
fläche für gemüse für drei personen also
zwei erwachsene und ein kind
und das werde dann überhaupt nicht
ausreichen weil von gemüse allein wird
man nicht satt im moment liegt mein
fokus sehr stark darauf meine familie
das ganze jahr über mit einer großen
vielfalt an gemüse zu versorgen diesen
gemüsegarten mit der großen vielfalt den
wird
als hundertprozentiger selbstversorger
natürlich auch haben wollen
aber daneben würde ich noch einen großen
fokus auf körnermais legen auf
körnerleguminosen noch mehr kartoffeln
anbauen
merck höher bis anbauen also die sachen
die wirklich satt machen weil gemüse
sagen wir meinen salat oder ein weiß
cool
der enthält so wenige kalorien dass man
sich davon allein ja überhaupt nicht
ernähren könnte aber man darf dabei auch
nicht die mehrjährigen pflanzen
vergessen was nämlich auch super viele
kalorien hat und richtig satt macht die
nussbäume ich würde also als allererstes
erstmals bäume pflanzen und auch
esskastanien je nachdem ob das in den
klima wo man wohnt funktioniert oder
nicht weil das dauert zwar ein paar
jahre beckham haselnüssen sind das
glaube ich vier jahre bis die anfangen
zu tragen
aber wenn die erstmal so weit sind dann
produzieren die ohne viel aufwand super
viele kalorien und die kann man dann
auch mit ins boot mission die kann man
malen die nüsse es dauert ein bisschen
die zu knacken aber da gibt es auch
möglichkeiten wie man viele nüsse auf
einmal von hand knappen kann aber wenn
ich 100 prozentiger selbstversorger sein
wollte dann würde ich so früh wie
möglich anfangen obstbäume zu pflanzen
und bäume zu pflanzen damit man dann
eben möglichst bald auch die ersten
ernten einfahren kann von mehrjährigen
gewächsen und es gibt kaum pflanzen die
so viele kalorien haben - das ist
einfach so die wenigsten von euch werden
wahrscheinlich den anspruch haben sich
zu 100 prozent selbst versorgen zu
wollen aber vielleicht habt ihr lust
mehr in richtung selbstversorgung zu
gehen und dann könnt ihr euch gerne
meinen kostenlosen anfänger guide
herunterladen da habe ich von den ersten
klängen die man so macht von den träumen
die man in sich trägt bis hin zu den
ersten schritten welche tiere wie viele
von welcher tier anschaffen wie groß
mein garten sein und so weiter das gehe
ich da alles mit die durch den geist
kannst du dir gerne als pdf hier unter
dem video herunterladen dafür linke ich
dir das ist absolut kostenlos so als
kleine einstiegshilfe in die
selbstversorgung von mir für euch außer
mais würde ich kein anderes gemüse
anbauen wenn ich mich zu 100 prozent
selber versorgen wollte weil klarheit
möglich dinkel oder wochen oder
weizen oder irgendein anderes getreide
im garten selber anzubauen aber dass
dann auch noch zu treffen und zu
verarbeiten ist super super aufwändig
bei mais ist das überhaupt nicht so
schwer
da kann man einfach vom träumen die
körner ablösen da gibt es auch kleine
einfache alter handmaschinen die man
manchmal noch auf dem flohmarkt bekommt
ich habe mir gerade eine bestellt weil
ich dieses jahr ausprobieren möchte hat
meist anzubauen und schon sehr gespannt
bin und den dann auch selber verarbeiten
möchte wir backen auch sehr viel mit
mais jetzt schon also dass es gekauft
damals dass es irgendeine hybrid worte
die man halt hier im laden bekommt aber
ich habe ein ganz spannendes buch
gelesen von einer meisterin
ja ist happy glaub ich weiß nicht genau
wie man es ausspricht kann euch gern das
buch unter dem video hier verlinken
die spricht ganz viel über meist die
braut ganz unterschiedliche maissorten
an und die sagt dieser meist also der
hochgezüchtete hybrid meist den man hier
bei uns bekommt ist er überhaupt nicht
so gut schmeckt ich finde ihn auch nicht
so besonders lecker wie die alten sorten
oder auch neu gezüchteten sorten wo man
wirklich auf geschmack geachtet hat
deswegen habe ich mir so ein paar sorten
rausgepickt da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche typen von meister man
sich damit beschäftigen will
in dem buch erzählt die kerwe jappy das
auch alles ganz genau was es dafür
unterschiedliche typen gibt wofür man
die verarbeiten kann das auch ganz viele
rezepte drin und das hätte ich dieses
jahr mal ausprobieren und mal schauen
wie das läuft unseren eigenen mais
anzubauen also was getreide an geht es
meist durch die ertragreichste und die
einfachste variante die man in einem
hausgarten selber anbauen kann der
maisanbau lässt sich auch sehr gut
verbinden mit der make a wish to ich
weiß nicht ob ich das was sagt es ist
die mischkultur also das gemeinsame an
bauern von mais stangenbohnen und kürbis
auf einem beet das hat mehrere vorteile
der kürbis bedeckt den boden und hält
den schönen beschattet und feucht wächst
zwischen den meisten dieser nach oben
zeigen ganz gut also die teilen sich den
platz ganz gut auf und die stangen
wurden die werden so um den meister
umgepflanzt dass die den mais als
stützpfeilern
die benutzten den meister zu sagen es
stützt hilfe und reich an den polen mit
stickstoff an
sowohl service als auch mais brauchen
viel stickstoff das sind beide stark
zierer und so hat man drei sehr sehr
nahrhafte kulturen auf einem beet
deswegen ist es auch so alt bewährt hat
man ja schon früher bei den inkas so
gemacht und das ist eine ganz tolle
mischkultur die einen sehr sehr gut satt
machen kann und die sehr gut dafür
geeignet ist eine familie zum teil zu
ernähren deswegen werde ich ganz ganz
viele münchner dieses jahr ausprobieren
unter anderem natürlich auch mit zucker
mais aber unter anderem auch mit hard
maissorten die ich gerne dieses jahr zum
ersten mal ausprobieren möchte ich bin
sehr gespannt ich hätte ich natürlich im
sommer berichten wie es denn so läuft
wird dem eis experiment
[Musik]
bei uns richtig kalorien landschaft sind
in siegen wir haben ihn für mich und ich
leicht die wurden hier in dem hänger auf
die arbeit hier
wenn man so nach den kalorien geht und
schaut wo man sich wirklich selbst
versorgen kann
eine wirklich tolle in den kaum kraft
nicht
und auch nur ein bisschen was da bekommt
man zwar nicht so eine tolle
milchleistung aber immerhin besser als
wenn man da ganz viel kraftfutter zu
kaufen muss und die verwandeln das gras
mehr wächst die zweige die blätter in
milch käse joghurt und den fleisch ich
bin die einzige in unserer familie die
fleisch ich habe letztes jahr zwei
ziegen geschlachtet eine große
einjähriges lämpchen also halb große
sicherheit und das hat für mich komplett
gereicht für die selbstversorgung mit
fleisch wenn wir alle drei fleisch essen
würden wäre das natürlich noch um
einiges mehr ziegen die wir da halten
und schlachten müssen und es ist auch
gar nicht so einfach ich liebe meine
tiere ich neben ihr wirklich über alles
ich finde es sehr sehr sehr schwierig
die selber zu essen
ich war selber auch lange zeit vegan und
sehr radikales hier recht lerin also
eigentlich genau das gegenteil von dem
was ich jetzt mache aber irgendwann habe
ich wieder angefangen fleisch zu essen
ich habe irgendwie so einen hunger drauf
gehabt dass ich dachte irgendwie will
mit meinen körper was damit zeigen dass
ich brauche jedes mal wenn ich im
supermarkt an der fleischtheke vorbei
gegangen bin hatte ich auf einmal spucke
im bund obwohl ich vorher nur tote
leichenteile gesehen habe und dann habe
ich angefangen wieder wild zu essen
und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht
eigene tiere zu halten ist schon nach
wild was frey gelebt hat eine der
höchsten möglichkeiten wenn man
vielleicht selber essen will dann muss
ich mir keine gedanken machen wie die
tiere gehalten wurden die ich esse wie
die geschlachtet wurden ich weiß von
anfang bis ende
genau das alles so abgelaufen ist wie
ich mir das vorstelle ich selbst bei
biofleisch das was man im supermarkt
bekommt wo man nicht den erzeuger
dahinter kennt und nicht die umstände
mir wäre das ja dass die siegel an sich
über die mir nicht ausreichen deswegen
macht ist
es macht viel spaß hier mit den ziegen
gerade auch das melken das ist so schön
dass es so eine meditative schöne zeit
jetzt gerade ist leider merkt pause also
bemerken im moment nicht deshalb müssen
wir alle milchprodukte ganz normal im
supermarkt einkaufen aber in der zeit wo
wir noch geborgen haben von einem halben
jahr hatten wir zwei mächtigen in der
hochsaison und sommer will die ziegen
durch dich milch geben
da hatten wir mit diesen minimalen
kraftfutter einsatz den wir haben unter
vier liter milch am tag es ist richtig
für drei personen daraus könnten
gelockert
frischkäse vita mozzarella eis joghurt
und so weiter machen und uns damit
komplett selber versorgen und wirklich
eine ganz tolle sache im scharfen findet
das auch funktionieren ich bin irgendwie
ein bisschen charmant als ein bisschen
blöd nicht ganz integriert
im moment haben wir aber keine ziele die
wir messen oder dessen freundin und
keine liebe merken
deswegen ist das im moment war sie nur
hobby weil da im moment überhaupt nichts
für uns warum kommt das hier ist eine
salami von mainz wir machen also wurst
ersten das fleisch ich habe damals
eingekauft ich hab was eingefroren
wir sind alle organe die herzen wir
verwenden das ganze tier also wirklich
von kopf bis fuß alles was man irgendwie
verwerten kann wird verwertet ich finde
dass man den tieren dann noch irgendwie
schuldig dass man dann mit anständigen
geht es man dann nichts verkommen lässt
und ja irgendwie auch das leckerste
mögliche gerichte aus zubereitet
das wenn sie versterben müssen ist
immerhin gewertschätzt wird weiß nicht
ob wir das nachvollziehen könnt aber das
ist mir super wichtig aber neben fall
steht auch jede menge fett an wenn man
tiere schlachtet das ist reines ziegen
fed davon haben wir mehrere gläser von
zwei ziegen und das kann man super zum
braten verwenden ich würde wenn ich
darauf aus wäre uns zu 100 prozent
selbst zu versorgen keine früchte
anbauen so wie ich das jetzt ein schätze
weil ölfrüchte sehr sehr aufwändig
abzubauen sind und wenn man tiere hält
und sowieso schlachtet dann auch sehr
viel fett an fällt es schmeckt auch
überhaupt nicht zickig also ich habe mir
das ganze vom geschmack die ecken
überhaupt nicht lecker vorgestellt aber
ich liebe ist da drin bratkartoffeln
oder rührei und da was auch immer zu
machen das ist wirklich ein ganz toller
ersatz für öl wenn man sich zu 100
prozent selbst versorgen möchte der
sowieso anfällt wenn man tiere
schlachtet ich glaube es ist durchaus
möglich sich zu 100 prozent mit essen
selbst zu versorgen
aber nicht so wie wir das aus dem
supermarkt gewohnt sind also dann würde
man seine ernährung schon um einiges
umstellen müssen und sehr viel auf
körnerleguminosen setzen auf hartplätzen
auf kartoffeln und kürbis und die
pflanzen die wirklich satt machen aber
dann kann man es wenn man bereit ist
sich diesen einschränkungen zu
unterwerfen
auf jeden fall schaffen sich zu 100
prozent mit essen selbst zu versorgen so
lange keine naturkatastrophe
dazwischenkommt oder irgendwas komplett
ausfällt
deswegen finde ich es auch immer wichtig
dass man sich da möglichst breit
aufstellt also wenn man möglichst aus
dem eigenen garten essen möchte wir
machen das auch obwohl wir uns nicht zu
100 prozent selbst versorgen aber mir
ist es schon wichtig dass wir möglichst
viel unseres essens selber anbauen und
da versuche ich mich auf eine sache zu
fokussieren und nur darauf zu setzen
wenn ich jetzt sage ich will meine
familie nur mit mais ernähren erstmal
werde es wahrscheinlich nicht so
besonders vor der ausgewogene ernährung
aber wenn dann es im spätsommer anfängt
zu regnen und die maiskörner nicht
richtig abtrocknen können an der pflanze
vielleicht anfangen zu schimmeln
dann hat man quasi alles auf eine karte
gesetzt deswegen ist es immer gut sich
breit aufzustellen
möglichst viele unterschiedliche
kalorien quellen zu haben aus denen man
sich ernähren
kann und nicht alles auf eine karte zu
setzen schreibt mir gerne mal in die
kommentare in welchen bereichen ihr euch
selbst versorgen wollt oder was eure
pläne sind hier trieben findet ihr ein
video in dem ich euch zeige wie viel
zeit uns die selbstversorgung auf dem
level wie wir sie betreiben also obst
gemüse eier milch und fleisch kostet
also wie viel zeit da in der woche
zusammenkommt die wir dafür aufbringen
müssen da unten findet ihr auch noch ein
spannendes video den selbstversorgung
staaten anfänger geld habe ich euch
unten in die video beschreibung gepackt
da wird euch den gerne herunter bis
dahin bis zum nächsten video